le monde
damn it et ses conséquences qu'en 8e
position à la motion de censure contre
le gouvernement l'ue et le rpr et nous
d'être ils ont décidé cet après midi
l'indépendance à pas de velours pour la
lettonie qui suit l'exemple de la
république de lituanie si elle accepte
pour une période transitoire de dialogue
avec moscou
à marseille plusieurs quartiers se
révoltant contre la drogue les parents
se mobilisent ils veulent fermer les
portes des sites
id-one reportage enfin grande soirée
cinéma français ce soir sur l'a3 de
films dont un inédit françois truffaut
un débat de nombreux invités ce soir sur
le plateau du 19 20
isabelle huppert
bonsoir l'opposition a décidé de déposer
une motion de censure contre le
gouvernement le débat politique
c'est ainsi durci depuis trois jours
l'adoption du projet de loi contre le
racisme la nuit dernière et les
conséquences de la loi sur la liste y
oppose à nouveau la droite et la gauche
le consensus même masqué sur l'économie
la défense et la politique étrangère est
telle qu'il faut bien trouver du grain à
moudre
mais ce grain light explosif car il peut
laisser des traces au sein même de la
société française nous y reviendrons
dans un instant mais il ya un événement
qui passent inaperçues qui pourtant très
important parce qu'il préoccupe tous les
habitants et sud de la france la
sécheresse deux ans de sécheresse et une
saison d'été qui s'annonce encore très
chaude dans la région de toulouse une
cellule de crise a été mise en place que
tu as d'irrigation et mesures
d'économies la situation est
catastrophique notamment pour les
agriculteurs de la montagne noire qui
sont les plus touchés reportage sur
place jean paul geai roi et nicolas
forest et actuellement nous devrions
avoir l'eau au niveau de l'ombre que
vous apercevez sur la paroi du barrage
le barrage des cammazes à quelques
kilomètres de revel ici sont recueillies
les eaux de ruissellement de la montagne
noire situation paradoxale
le sommet de cette montagne est un des
endroits les plus arrosées de france les
années normales
en revanche les terres exploitées plus
var sont particulièrement aride qualité
du sol et présence permanente du vent
d'autan un puissant vent d'est
particulièrement desséchant aujourd'hui
le barrage est à la moitié de son niveau
habituel à pareille époque nouvelle
année de sécheresse
déjà la récolte des points s'annonce
très mauvaise disons qu'il y aura un
quart d'heure récolte ce qui a le plus
souffert de la sécheresse et dider puis
lé froid vent la pluie qu'il a fait
faire mars
c'est dur il faut le faire paître le
couper de suite en association avec un
autre agriculteur dit sa case exploite
140 hectares de terre comme les autres
exploitants de revel il a depuis vingt
ans beaucoup misé sur l'irrigation
elle a permis l'apparition de cultures à
haut revenu comme le maïs semences
achetées davance par les compagnies
céréales
r non pas c'est pas d'eau dans les
barrages d'irrigations 0 pour lui sa
case une perte sèche de 300 mille francs
et la nécessité de réinvestir magique
pour repartir sur 140 hectares en
polyculture il me faut 400 mille francs
de dettes
il me faut avancer 4,5 milliards et si
je les trouve pas la banque
ici je les ai pas dans mes bénéfices
intérieur je suis jamais par écrit sur
le paillasson
les emprunts calamité ont permis de
repartir pour cette année unis devant la
nouvelle sécheresse annoncée dès cet
hiver on a choisi des cultures à moindre
consommation d'eau la cellule
préfectorale anti sécheresse
ap le choix de sacrifier le tourisme
fluvial du canal du midi pour donner aux
agriculteurs 50% de leur évaluation
moyenne
il a plu au mois d'avril et si rien
d'autre ne vient dans les trois
prochaines semaines les récoltes risque
de nouveau d'être sinistre et revel
attend toujours que le ciel veuille bien
lui tomber sur la tête
je vous le disais contre-offensive de
l'opposition le rpr udf et udc ont
décidé de déposer une motion de censure
contre le gouvernement et ont ainsi
exaucer le voeu de jacques chirac michel
lemaire choqué par les conséquences de
la loi d'aministie mettront aussi à
saisir les mouvements d'opinion et a
tenté de se dégager du discrédit qui
pèse sur l'ensemble de la classe
politique l'opposition lance contre le
gouvernement sa grande offensive de
printemps
est-ce qu'il ya encore une justice qui
est le même pour tous en france ou non
est naturellement
vont pas envisager un instant à accepter
l'idée qu'il y ait de justice la raison
pour laquelle les trois groupes de
l'opposition ont décidé de déplacer
cette motion de censure les centristes
dans l'abstention avait permis le vote
de la loi en boîte aujourd'hui le pas
sans état d'âme ce qu'ils s'étaient
abstenus sur le texte de loi sur
l'amnistié ne se sont pas abstenus pour
cela ils ont été trompés
et c'est parce qu'ils ont été trompés
qu'ils estiment qu'une motion de censure
aujourd'hui est la seule réponse
possible à l'action du gouvernement
l'assemblée se donnait alors le grand
frisson le gouvernement rocard
allaient-ils trembler sur ses bases
c'est le pc qui détenait la réponse
andré lajoinie n'a pas vraiment laissé
planer le suspense on laisse entendre
qu'il ne se rallierait pas à ce texte
temps voulu et ce projet de loi continue
de susciter des remous dans le monde de
la justice
trois juges d'instruction de toulouse
sont ainsi prêts à remettre en liberté
vi personne inculpée d'atteinte aux
biens et placé en détention provisoire
l'autre débat porte sur les moyens de
lutter plus efficacement contre le
racisme le projet de loi a été adopté à
l'aube après une longue nuit de
discussions et de débats 80 amendements
avaient été déposés
le texte a finalement été votée mais
sérieusement modifié retour sur cette
nuit de débat à l'assemblée nationale
françoise roy après une nuit de
discussions très agité et une bataille
d'amendements les députés ont finalement
adopté ce matin la proposition de loi
communiste réprimant toute acte raciste
antisémite ou xénophobe
seuls les socialistes et les communistes
ont voté pour l'opposition rpr udf et
udc s'est prononcé contre
refusant un texte je cite liberticide
est élaboré à la sauvette c'est
marie-france stirbois qui a mené avec
véhémence le décor assez rhino
poissonnier assassiné par un marocain
mohamad tout voleur de métier patrick
bard en 22 ans maçon tué à coups de
couteau par medida game marocain didier
roques 30 ans tu es pas un algérien
mohamed my dinh pour différends
financiers la même chose pour un étal
ouchy ce sont là des agressions racistes
anti fontaine tels abus
voulais pas en parler ne monte et il
faut le dénoncer pain d'antan vraiment
le courage de le faire
vous n'avez pas le courage vous êtes ne
m'abuse étrangers voilà ce que vous êtes
le racisme est un délit ce n'est pas
nouveau et le texte adopté à l'assemblée
nationale vise à frapper plus dur et
plus large
les députés ont ainsi adopté 5
amendements du gouvernement dont un
permettant de considérer comme un délit
le révisionnisme thèse qui consiste à
nier le génocide juif de la seconde
guerre mondiale après la grosse colère
des communistes contre la réforme de la
saisine et le statut renault le
gouvernement a décidé de calmer le jeu
avec le pcf sachez encore que l'un des
domaines où la législation a été
fortement renforcée n'est autre que la
liberté de la presse
les magistrats auront désormais plus de
pouvoir et plus de moyens pour
sanctionner les publications à caractère
raciste maître kiejman avocat et
spécialiste de ce type de questions y
est plutôt favorable on les coûts tout
de suite loi de 1881 révisée en 1972 ne
prévoyait pas par exemple l'infraction
qui est lié ce qu'on appelle le
révisionnisme la négation des crimes
contre l'humanité puis peut-être qu'elle
ne prévoyait pas assez largement la
possibilité à certaines associations de
se constituer porté ici ville dans ses
procès et enfin peut-être que la loi
nouvelle en introduisant cette sanction
très particulière qu'est ligne
l'égibilité peut conduire certains
hommes politiques à réfléchir avant de
tenir des propos qui eux sont carrément
odieux et irresponsable tensions dans
notre pays des tentes à l'étranger
détente est ouest avec une décision de
george bush les etats-unis ne briseront
pas les armes nucléaires du champ de
bataille en europe et cette décision
aura des conséquences importantes pour
notre continent
pierre babey j'ai décidé de mettre un
terme au programme des missiles de
courte portée et d'annuler la
modernisation de ces armes stationnées
en europe de la maison blanche cet après
midi george bush à formaliser l annonce
faite ce matin par james baker ses
collègues des affaires étrangères au
siège de l'otan à bruxelles
un missile de courte-portée voilà
exactement ce que c'est c'est une fusée
sol-sol
gilles nucléaire ici un lens
sensiblement équivalent à domicile
pluton est capable de propulser sa
charge à 110 km 110 kilomètres à partir
de ce côté-ci de l'ex rideau de fer cela
veut dire qu'il a pour cible la hongrie
la tchécoslovaquie et surtout
l'allemagne de l'est autrement dit un
territoire prochainement rattaché à un
pays membre de l'otan la rfa absurde
impensable ce matin à bruxelles les 16
ministres ont également indiqué que
paris accueillera bien le sommet sur la
sécurité en europe à la fin de l'année
et qu'un nouveau sommet de l'otan se
tiendra fin juin ou début juillet à
londres et dans les pays de l'est ce
l'actualité toujours marquée par les
manifestations roumanie et par la
volonté d'indépendance d'une autres
républiques baltes la lettonie son
volonté d'indépendance
oui mais avec prudence si la lettonie
semble vouloir suivre l'exemple de la
république de lituanie
ces parlementaires sont apparemment
moins pressés ils accepteraient même une
période de transition avant de quitter
l'union soviétique francine vraiment
après la lituanie après l'estonie la
lettonie veut retrouver son indépendance
la troisième république balte dont
presque la moitié de la population est
d'origine russe préfère une stratégie ou
un radical que celle choisie par la
lituanie venu en voisin vitaux tu as
lens berg is le numéro un lituanien 1 6
l ouverture de cette session historique
du parlement letton demain les députés
voteront pour la restauration de la
dépendance de 1920 et le rétablissement
de la constitution mairiga veut éviter
une confrontation avec moscou et prévoit
pour parvenir à l'indépendance
une période de transition de trois à
quatre ans la république de lettonie
perdrait au passage son appellation de
socialistes en lettonie la détermination
d'obtenir l'indépendance est aussi forte
qu à vilnius
mais ici on semble vouloir prendre des
précautions le parlement letton fera
appel à la communauté internationale
pour que le statut des pays baltes soit
examiné dans le cadre des négociations
est think i 2 par ailleurs les députés
les taux ont adressé une lettre à
mikhaïl gorbatchev pour que le numéro un
soviétique fassent preuve de
compréhension envers la lettonie
en roumanie le vice-premier ministre des
nouvelles comme l'affirment les
élections auront bien lieu à la date
prévue c'est-à-dire le 20 mai prochain
malgré les manifestations et la
contestation le gouvernement ne veut pas
de dialogue avec l'opposition une
opposition parfois très fermes pour
preuve la déclaration de jean accordé 1
cet après midi elle affirme je cite
consomment chez secoue détruisez les
villages ion iliescu épais trait romane
assister à des réceptions
elle qualifie les actuels gouvernants
romain de communistes convaincus
et ce débat se produit aussi en france
il y à un ex dissident qui prend lui la
défense du président est liée aux coûts
et de quais très remaniée il s'agit de
virgile tanaz l'écrivain a décidé de
rester en france mais suit de très près
ce qui se passe à bucarest à nouveau un
beau livre ma roumanie chez ram ces
rencontres entre marie odile pas niaise
et vierge est anase regarde un ancien
opposant à la veille des élections
roumaine pour virgil tanase élections un
espoir pour son pays avoir enfin un
pouvoir légal démocratiquement élu il ne
comprend pas que l'opposition veuille
les repousser pas plus qu'il ne comprend
les critiques
la méfiance à l'égard du gouvernement
c'est en donnant latéraux paysans dans
la liberté de la presse en laissant la
liberté de circulation des gens tout ce
qui se passe toutes les mesures qui ont
été prises depuis la révolution en
roumanie
si ça c'est du comice rallonge colloque
ont exposé des communistes quand on
vient me dire que les anciens des les
gens sont sont encore au pouvoir
manille j'ai envie de citer quelqu'un
c'est antoine vitez qui vient mourir
antoine vitez a été un moment et un
communiste stalinien
je ne vois pas pourquoi antoine vitez
peu changé en bien et quelqu'un qui
était en roumanie ne peut pas changer
je revendique pour lui qui était au
parti communiste roumain la même
indulgence que nous avons eu un bébé
thèse quand on a la chance d'une des
élections et d'une d'un passage à la
démocratie
essayer de déstabiliser le pouvoir qui
est une tâche tellement énorme devant
soi ou encore pop c'est un geste
politiquement responsable
virgile la nasa confiance dans le
pouvoir confiance dans l'avenir de la
roumanie
et pourtant il ne rentrera pas dans son
pays si l'homme et roumains l'écrivain
lui ce sont français joseph pham berg
heures a été livré à l'allemagne de
l'ouest à l'issue d'une traque de 40 ans
il s'agit de l'un des plus grands
criminels de guerre nazis il vivait
tranquillement en argentine classée
bastien difficile d'imaginer la cruauté
d'un criminel de guerre nazi sous les
traits de ce vieillard à la démarche
hésitante
joseph schwank arg commandant ss dirigé
plusieurs camps de travail en pologne et
à offrir la justice ou est ce seulement
ne soupçonne être responsable
directement de la mort de 1000
travailleurs forcés de la déportation de
plusieurs milliers de juifs arrêtés par
les français à la fin de la guerre il
s'évade et trouvent asile en argentine
flux offre aussi la nationalité
après 17 ans d'une longue traque la
justice allemande vient d'obtenir son
extradition en mettant le pied ce matin
sur le sol allemand
johan berger à 78 retrouve un passé
accablant dont il aura désormais à
répondre
l'échec relatif que l'on observe dans la
plupart des pays contre le trafic de
drogue ainsi désormais certains citoyens
qui ne sont ni policier ni magistrats à
s'en occuper directement on l'a vu
récemment à madrid
on le voit aujourd'hui à marseille 1-2
puis
hier deux quartiers de la ville se
révoltent contre les trafiquants les
acteurs de cette mobilisation sont de
simples par an il refuse de voir leurs
enfants menacés par la drogue ou par des
seringues abandonnées est temps de
fermer les portes de leur cité aux
toxicomanes reportage dans le quartier
l'onudc à marseille dominique jamais
citer le duc 7e secteur de marseille 120
logements familiaux loyer mensuel moyen
1200 francs depuis vendredi l'accès de
la cité est filtrée par les locataires
motif la drogue ça ce sont les seringue
que vous avez trouvé ici même que j'ai
ramassé derrière là pour dîner n'avais
plus mes récentes ont mis à la poubelle
et c'est pour ça que vous avez décidé de
bloquer la cité à nord mais c'est pour
tout ça on en a marre on met plus en
avant dans la cité on a des enfants les
enfants sont en danger
malgré le ramassage quotidien effectuée
par les mères de famille
on en trouve encore un peu partout dans
la verdure où vont jouer les enfants
derrière les bâtiments dans les
logements inoccupés accessible de
l'extérieur sans difficulté dans les
voitures comme celle ci acheté à crédit
au début de l'année
squatter la nuit est désormais
inutilisable
ils ne sont pas ici ça m'a pas dit si
c'est pour ça ce n'est pas du quartier
12 secondes six yeux et vous êtes sûr
qu'il y en a pas qui habite la cité a
certainement qui va rester encore un peu
et qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire là
c'est un projet qu'il faut des musées
mais là ne s'arrêtent pas les malheurs
de la cité le duc privé d'entretien elle
offre à l'extérieur de multiples
cachette
quant à l'intérieur ils ne proposent
même plus un minimum de confort on n'a
pas d'eau chaude n'a pas de chauffage là
et il autorise qui parle vraiment tous
les côtés six pièces lycée vraiment seul
c'est vivable invivable avec la drogue
invivable sans elle c'est peut-être
aussi le message de la cipd et révoltés
depuis trois jours regardez bien vos
tickets de caisse lors de vos achats
dans les grandes surfaces le risque
d'erreur n'est pas négligeable
si l'on en croit véronique neiertz le
secrétaire d'état à la consommation
encore faut-il pouvoir lire ces fameux
codes barres en quête de jean marc pitte
et de philippe chasse à ces petites
barres sont-elles coupable de tous les
crimes dont on les accuse et serait en
effet responsable de plus de
% d'erreurs en fait il faut minimiser la
larme lancé par la secrétaire d'état à
la consommation
tout d'abord les erreurs favorables et
défavorables aux clients s'équilibre
globalement d'ailleurs les consommateurs
sont loin d'être traumatisés vous
vérifiez n'est jamais vide et si jamais
avoir suggéré un lien même s'il échappe
parfois la vigilance des clients les
erreurs existent pourtant
mais l'informatisation n'est pas
vraiment un remettre en cause les fautes
sont la plupart du temps humaine une
mauvaise coordination peut nuire quand
les prix changent vite et souvent
lorsque nous avons un articles en
promotions et que la promotion arrive à
son terme
eh bien nous devons veillons à et
veiller à ce que le prix de notre
fichier soit soit remis au bon prix les
erreurs existait avant les codes-barres
et dans les mêmes proportions les
clients reprocherait plutôt à cette
innovation d'être difficilement
accessible moi j'aimais mieux lui aussi
un système avec les éthiques
ça c'est exact parce que renvoyait ce
qu'on achète ces critiques ne suffiront
certainement pas à remettre en cause le
code-barres car il présente un avantage
de poids
le gain de temps un sens nuit là ni
incendie la nuit dernière en région
parisienne voici tout de suite les
autres faits marquants de l'actualité en
france grâce aux images de nos stations
régionales commentaire nathalie
darrigrand les flammes de 10 à 15 mètres
de haut s'est tenue dans les bois de
milly la forêt dans l'eifel
plus de 100 pompiers cinq heures
d'intervention ont été nécessaires au
total 30 hectares de forêt ont brûlé
donc
crash d'un mirage f1 cet après midi sur
la base aérienne d'orange
l'accident s'est produit lors du
décollage le pilote est sain et sauf une
enquête a été ouverte
ouverture de marge du procès en
correctionnelle de quatre assistantes
sociales accusé de non dénonciation de
crime
elle n'aurait pas signalé les abus
sexuels d'un père sur sa fille ce
dernier a été récemment condamné à 10
ans de prison
danic cet après midi à la poste de
perpignan de vieux messieurs se sont
violemment apostrophé si violemment que
l'un a tiré avec un pistolet d'alarmé
sur l'autre plus de peur que de mal la
victime est légèrement blessé selon les
premiers éléments d'enquêté
il s'agirait d'un règlement de comptes
passionnel une seule lumière une seule
lumière rouge à tendance rouge et
parfois ça passait au blanc les eaux de
pluie belge ont-ils passé la frontière
ce jeune homme en est persuadé hier soir
alors qu'il se promenait avec sa petite
amie si à lieu-saint-amand il a aperçu
trois points lumineux dans le ciel les
gendarmes affirment prendre affaire très
au sérieux
soirée ciné sur l'a3 une semaine avant
l'ouverture du festival de cannes soirée
riche avec deux films violette nozière
de claude chabrol à 20h31 inédit de
françois truffaut à 00h30 les mistons
entre ces deux films un débat sur le
cinéma français je vous en parlerai dans
un instant et pour ouvrir en quelque
sorte cette soirée exceptionnelle sur le
cinéma français
isabelle huppert son soir vous allez
parce que vous êtes le personnage de
violette nozière c'est une histoire
vraie en fait c'est une histoire qu'il
reconstitue une histoire vraie oui tout
à fait c'était après un fait divers
célèbre qui s'était passé en 1933
c'était l'histoire de cette jeune fille
qui avait cette jeune femme qui avait
empoisonné son père et sa mère et savait
à l'époque beaucoup frappé les
imaginations y compris celle des
surréalistes les poètes surréalistes ont
beaucoup écrit sur elle et cela vous
avait valu un prix d'interprétation à
cannes en 78 tout à fait alors on va
parler du cinéma français je vais pas
vous demander ce que vous comptez faire
ce que vous allez faire on va parler
actuellement de l'état du cinéma
on dit qu'il a éprouvé certaines
difficultés est ce que c'est un
sentiment vous éprouvez on a toujours
dit je crois oui c'est un sentiment
qu'on peut éprouver quelques fois quand
on quand on se penche sur les chiffres
de la fréquentation mais moi je pense
que c'est un cinéma qui est
extraordinairement créatif et est vivant
et très très diversifié et il faut
surtout pas se livrer dans des
comparaisons hasardeuses comme on le
fait souvent par exemple avec le cinéma
américain je crois que c'est la france
est un des pays au monde quand même où
le ou les films les plus les plus
novateurs se font probablement avec le
plus de facilité et on sait bien
quelquefois que les les choses
novatrices ne sont pas c'est forcément
qui engendre le plus de courant le plus
grand bond dans sa fréquentation ou sait
pas on va pas rentrer dans le débat
maintenant mais vous sentez ce
frémissement avec son cinéma nouveaux
bons sans plus ce frémissement s'est
adjugé la france est avec cyrano de
bergerac avec le film de besson avec eux
d'affaires oui je crois que il ya une
encore une fois il ya une
une diversité qui est exceptionnellement
cinéma français merci isabelle les ce
débat aura lieu à 23h10 avec de
nombreuses personnalités mais d'abord et
rita l'héritage du rock avec le bus des
six et un prix spécial pour le meilleur
groupe de la décennie si je vous dit
catherine ringer et fred chichin vous me
répondez vous l'avez dit rita mitsouko
ils ont obtenu hier le bus de la
décennie et cela valait bien un boeuf
reportage michel vial et thierry isaac
zéro heure trente la nuit dernière au
bus palladium justice est enfin rendue à
rita mitsouko dans ces jurys successifs
le bus dassier avait en effet
curieusement négliger l'une des plus
éclatantes sinon la plus éclatante
révélation du rock français de ces dix
dernières années
catherine ringer et fred chichin
musiciens intrépide et personnalités
acide de drôles d'oiseaux qui ont
singulièrement décaper le rock hexagonal
il avait dit tout à l'heure que vous
n'aviez fait que trois disques et on
tourne pourquoi
la lenteur musicale et la passion de ne
pas être suivi de ne pas être aidé de ne
pas être compris proches le système qui
est comme ça il critiquait ce système
oui on travaille avec passion dans la
conversation rita mitsouko ne pratique
pas facilement la confidence sur scène
en revanche c'est une autre histoire
nos compères se font peu prier pour
donner libre cours à leur fantaisie et
parfois dérangeantes rejoint lors du
traditionnel boeuf du bus d'acier par
des musiciens des [ __ ] vertes de
jade bio et par axel bauer en troll
autant vous dire qu'on a dans ces prêts
tard cette nuit pour ne pas dire p tôt
ce matin sur la piste du bus palladium
fin de ce 19 ans j'aurai le plaisir de
vous retrouver sur l'a3 à 23h10 pour
cette émission sur le cinéma français
avec de nombreux comédiens carole
bouquet gérard depardieu qui nous a
accordé un entretien à new york
hippolyte girardot de nombreux metteurs
en scène comme alexandre arcady jean
jacques beineix claude lelouch bertrand
tavernier
francis girod ou allah je suis là et
bien sûr l'homme du cinéma français l'un
des hommes daniel toscan du plantier
après l'information avant cela le
prochain rendez vous avec l'information
soir 3 présenté par marc hautement à
22h45 et tout de suite
la météo complète nos flancs cela henri
chapier sera là aussi bonsoir bonsoir